foreign
good afternoon everybody
every day our scientists are learning
more about this new covid variant but
there's one thing that we already know
for sure and that is that right now our
best single defense against Omicron is
to get vaccinated Omicron I should say
is to get vaccinated and to get boosted
if you're boosted your immune response
will be stronger so yesterday in
addition to offering a second dose to
all 12 to 15 year olds the independent
jcvi recommended that boosters should
now be offered to everyone over 18 and
that we halve the minimum gap between a
second dose and a booster from six
months to three months that means that
over 14 million more adults have now
become eligible for a booster in England
alone so I'm here today with the health
secretary Javid and Amanda Pritchard
chief executive of NHS England to set
out our plan to make this happen
the Target that we've set ourselves is
to offer a booster to everyone eligible
by the end of January and as with the
first Jabs we'll be working through
people by age group going down in
five-year bands because it's vital that
the older and the more clinically
vulnerable get that added protection
first so even if you've had your second
job over three months ago and you're now
eligible please don't try and book until
the NHS says it's your turn
we've already done almost 18 million
boosters across the UK
but we've got millions more to do to
protect the most vulnerable
then we'll move down the cohorts rapidly
and working together with the devault
administrations we want to ramp up
capacity across the whole United Kingdom
to the levels we achieved in the
previous vaccination effort
we're going to be throwing everything at
it in order to ensure that everyone
eligible is offered that booster in as I
say just over two months
across England will have more than 1500
Community Pharmacy sites vaccinating
people near where you live
all of our sites will increase their
capacity and will stand up extra
Hospital hubs on top of those already
active
there'll be temporary vaccination
centers popping up like Christmas trees
and will deploy at least 400 military
personnel to assist the efforts of our
NHS alongside of course the Fantastic
Jabs Army of volunteers
I know the frustration that we all feel
with this Omicron variant the sense of
uh of exhaustion that we could be going
through all this all over again but
today I want to stress this uh today
that's that's the wrong thing to feel
because today our position is and always
will be immeasurably better than it was
a year ago what we're doing is taking
some proportionate precautionary
measures while our scientists crack the
Omicron code and while we get the added
protection of those boosters into the
arms of those who need the most so we're
going to get behind the men and women of
our NHS who've saved so many lives on
the front line and run our vaccination
program uh for a year almost without a
break as they have and who are going
back into the breach yet again and I
want to say on behalf of the entire
country a thank you to each and every
one of them for their their
extraordinary efforts
and the best way we can all show our
gratitude
is by doing our bit and stepping forward
when our time comes to get that boost up
I've been waiting uh patiently for for
my moment to come and it's happening on
Thursday I'm pleased to say so whenever
your turn comes get your booster and ask
your friends and your family to do the
same
it's time for another Great British
vaccination effort we've done it before
and we're going to do it again and let's
not give this virus a second chance
thank you for answering the hand over to
satch
thank you prime minister a year ago this
week this country made headlines when we
became the first nation in the Western
World to authorize a vaccine for covert
19. this kicked off one of the greatest
Collective Endeavors this nation has
seen in peace time
and think how far we've come since then
115 million jobs right across the UK and
a booster program that is expanding at a
phenomenal Pace today we've hit that
Milestone of 18 million booster doses
across the UK and the daily number of
Jabs has gone up a third since the start
of this month
not only that but we've delivered more
booster doses than any other country
with the exception of the USA and China
and that is something that we can all be
very proud of and I'd like to thank the
NHS the armed forces the volunteers and
everyone who's done so much to make this
program a success as well as every
single person that has come forward for
their job
thanks to you we've made so much
progress over the course of a year that
we have now weakened the link between
cases and hospitalizations and deaths
this is the real world protection that
our vaccination program provides
boosters in particular pay a very huge
part the booster dose provides a much
higher antibody response than the
primary course so it's more important
than ever that people step up and get
protected
we're now dealing of course with this
new variant Omicron which the World
Health Organization said just yesterday
they said that it poses a very high
Global risk
there have now been 13 confirmed cases
in England and also nine confirmed cases
in Scotland and we expect to see these
numbers rising over the next few days
there's a lot we don't know of course
and our scientists are working night and
day to learn more about this new variant
and what it means for our response
our strategy is to buy the time we need
to assess this new variant while doing
everything we can to slow the spread of
the virus and to strengthen our defenses
one important defense is antivirals
we've already secured hundreds of
thousands of doses of two antivirals
that have the potential to speed up
recovery and to stop infections from
progressing
another of course is that vaccination
program it's true that we don't yet have
a full picture of how our vaccines
respond to this new variant but although
it's possible for them to be less
effective it's unlikely that they have
no Effectiveness against serious disease
so the best way that we can strengthen
our protective wall is to get as many
Jabs in arms as possible
I asked the jcvi our independent expert
advisors to look urgently at our
vaccination program in light of this new
variant and as the Prime Minister just
set out will we massively expanding
booster doses in line with the jcvi
advice this includes halving the dose
interval for booster jobs from 6 months
to three months expanding the booster
doses to include all remaining adults
aged 18 and above and offering booster
doses for people who are
immunosuppressed I'd like to thank the
jcvi for acting with such speed in
response to this Potential Threat
this means we're now able to put our
booster program on steroids and protect
even more people even more quickly
we've got the Jabs thanks to the
brilliant work of our vaccines task
force who've made sure that we've had a
strong supply of vaccines all the way
throughout this pandemic and today we
are setting up our plan to get those
Jabs into arms and I will shortly be
hearing a bit more from Amanda
we've set some hugely ambitious targets
and we're asking a huge amount from the
NHS but I have no doubt that they will
rise to the challenge just as they have
done throughout this pandemic
I know that the developments of the past
few days have been worrying for some
people
and that we've brought back memories
this what we're seeing recently has
brought back memories of the strain of
the last winter
but although we can't say with certainty
what lies ahead we have one huge
advantage that we didn't have back then
our vaccination program which has
already done so much to keep this virus
at Bay
but these defenses will only keep us
safe if we use them
this is a national mission
and we all have a role to play
if we want to give ourselves the best
chance of a Christmas with our loved
ones the best thing we can all do is
step up roll up our sleeves and get
protected when the time comes
I'll now hand over to Amanda
thank you
so yesterday afternoon the government
accepted the jcbi recommendation to
accelerate the NHS covid-19 vaccination
program in response to the Potential
Threat from the new Omicron variant
that's why I am writing to the NHS
setting out the steps we need to take to
operationalize this new guidance
as we've just heard jcvi have advised
the gap between the second dose and the
booster should be halved from six to
three months this means an additional
6.9 million over 40s will be newly
eligible for a booster they've also
advised that those between the ages of
18 and 39 are also now eligible at three
months after that second dose meaning
that more than seven million people in
this age group will be eligible for a
booster
and on top of this again as we've just
heard jcvi has recommended the
introduction of fourth Jabs for those
who are most vulnerable because they're
undergoing chemotherapy or have other
problems with their immune system
the NHS covered vaccination program was
already in its most complex phase and
staff are now working at Breakneck speed
to respond to this the biggest challenge
in the biggest change in eligibility
since the program has launched
in line with jcv advice we'll be
vaccinating the most vulnerable first
and then opening up further just as we
did in those opening waves of the
program
so while changes to the booking system
protocols and Patient Group directive
are put in place we will continue to
vaccinate the millions of people who
were already eligible for their Top-Up
Jabs
the booking service will then open up to
others in their 40s and older people who
would previously have had to wait six
months before moving then on to younger
age groups
so if you were not already eligible
please do not contact the NHS we will
let you know when it's your turn to take
up the offer
it is Our intention to ensure that
everyone eligible for a booster is given
the chance to book one before the end of
January
before to make this happen we will need
to expand vaccination capacity right
across the NHS hundreds of hospitals are
of course already jabbing their own
staff we're now asking them to vaccinate
other local NHS workers eligible
patients and social Care staff as well
around 30 hospitals are already offering
jobs to the public through the national
booking service and dozens more will be
coming online from early next week
our hard-working GPS Community
Pharmacists and their Primary Care
colleagues have delivered the Lion's
Share of the vaccination so far
we're looking at how we can help them to
do even more Jabs by cutting other
burdens on them to free up clinicians
time
and we will ensure that they are
properly rewarded for their efforts
particularly when they take time to
visit vulnerable housebound patients who
can't travel to vaccination sites
so the payment for standard delivery of
vaccinations will increase to 15 pounds
a shot until the end of January to
increase capacity on Sundays at when
many Community pharmacists are not
usually open will offer an additional
five pounds a shot and to ensure we're
prioritizing the most vulnerable we'll
offer a 30 pound premium for
vaccinations delivered to the house
found until the end of next month
the CQC have agreed to continue their
pause on routine inspections of general
practice to help free up clinicians time
and we're also looking at whether we can
safely reduce or even eliminate the
15-minute wait after the job is
delivered so we could potentially
increase the number of people able to
get jobs every day in smaller sites like
pharmacies
we now have nearly 3 000 sites available
across the country that's almost double
the number that we had back in February
but to help make it quicker and easier
to get a job local areas will also be
using mobile vaccination units which can
allow people to get protected basically
on their doorsteps
so these are the steps that I will be
setting out to the NHS
but it can't happen overnight
particularly given the other pressures
facing NHS staff who are working
extremely hard they're working hard to
address the backlogs that have
inevitably built up in less Urgent Care
while hospitals cared for more than half
a million people with covid as
inpatients and of course many many more
in the community they're working
extremely hard to deal with a rebound in
demand for Urgent emergency care and of
course they are working extremely hard
to care today for those thousands of
patients in hospital and in the
community with covid
however as the world faces this new
threat we can take confidence in what
the NHS has achieved so far
next week we Mark the first anniversary
of the world's first Pfizer covid-19 jab
delivered here in England by the NHS
one year on the NHS covid-19 vaccination
program is closing in on 100 million
Jabs administered in England and since
the booster campaign began just over 10
weeks ago in England NHS staff have
delivered over 15 million Top-Up jobs
and NHS staff continue to go above and
beyond to vaccinate people
just this week during storm Arwen an NHS
team delivered hundreds of booster
vaccinations in North Yorkshire like
Candlelight
of course the success of the NHS
vaccination program has not been down to
Health Service staff alone but the
result of a huge National effort
since its launch we've been supported in
particular by our amazing volunteers and
many other partners
as we launch A Renewed drive to protect
our country we're working with our
colleagues at RVs and St John to recruit
tens of thousands more volunteers and
from Monday we'll start to recruit to 10
000 paid vaccinator roles
so if you are able to help then please
do apply or volunteer your help can help
us protect more people and save more
lives
the NHS and the entire country are
living through a once in a generation
event and we all have a role to play I
am confident that with public support
the can-do spirit of the NHS will once
again win through and behalf of all NHS
staff I would just like to thank
everybody who's taken up the offer of
ajab and urge again everyone watching to
keep up their enthusiasm for this
program by accepting the invite for each
of the Jabs available to you when it's
your turn
thanks very much Amanda that's good
questions from the public first to Alex
from Surrey asks given that the Omicron
variant spreads more in crowded and
non-ventilated spaces why are you not
expanding the face covering requirement
to higher risk indoor setting such as
Cinemas and theaters giving these
settings are of greater risk than shops
and transportation well Alex thank you
very much for that and that's a question
that's been asked a lot in the uh why
why aren't we doing face coverings or
all over uh the place and the answer is
that we're we're trying to take a
balanced and a proportionate approach
Alex uh slowing down the spread of of
Omicron while we get to the bottom of uh
of of the exact effect that it has but
uh Sarah generally you want to to add on
that no that that's right p.m and of
course we we keep all this under review
but we we still don't know enough about
the the variant to to understand
properly it's uh spread compared to
Delta uh but uh as as we learn more we
will certainly share that thank you uh
tanith from Surrey asks given the
concerns of the Omicron variant being
more highly transmissible and possibly
bypassing the vaccines what does the
government doing to protect those
designated as clinically extremely
vulnerable especially in those who are
immunosuppressed in which the current
vaccines do not have the same efficacy
as in say a normal healthy person who is
not immunocompromised Savage I think you
you touched on that earlier on yeah one
thing I can certainly share with tanith
and all those uh listening is that the
antivirals that we ProCure do the way
the antivirals work the two I mentioned
uh earlier so we've got 730 000 courses
already one of them has already been
approved by mhra our independent
regulator I think we're the first in the
world to approve it and because they
work in a very different way to the
vaccines we're confident that they would
provide a high degree of protection and
of course the priority for those
antivirals will be those that are
clinically extremely vulnerable great
thanks very much uh and thank you tanith
let's go to Vicki Young on BBC News
Vicky
top health advisors suggested this
morning that we should all minimize our
socializing over Christmas was she right
to say that do you agree with her do you
think that we should be canceling
Christmas parties right now and to
Amanda Pritchard can the NHS we know
there's a lot of pressure especially
going into winter can the NHS really
cope with what is a massive expansion
really of this vaccine program and to uh
Secretary of State what can be done to
perspect those who haven't had any
vaccines at all we're of course talking
today a lot about the booster program
but we do know that particularly in
hospitals a large proportion of those
that have not had any at all thanks very
much Vicky so the answer is is no the
guidance Remains the Same and uh we uh
we're trying to take a balanced and
proportionate approach and as I
explained on Saturday when uh when
talking for the first time to everybody
about Omicron we're really dealing with
uh with two uh variants at the same time
we've got the the measures in place to
uh to fight uh Delta uh which we think
are appropriate and then we're bringing
in some tougher measures to uh to stop
the seeding the the the rapid seeding of
Omicron in this country to give us the
time we need to get the boosters in and
of course to find out more so that those
measures as you know are uh the tough
measures at the the borders the PCR test
uh uh when you arrive uh quarantine
until uh you've got a negative result uh
then uh tougher measures on masks and
making sure that a contact for anybody
anybody who comes into contact with an
Omicron a case also has to has to
quarantine we think that's the right
balance uh you and uh we will keep it of
course under uh under constant uh review
and I should say of course we've got
tougher measures uh even tougher
measures for travel for those countries
for those 10 countries uh that uh seem
to have particular uh problems with uh
with Omicron
is that it I think that was it good
thank you uh let's oh
to Amanda about the NHS oh sorry God has
got a map sorry thank you and so look I
think there is absolutely no doubt that
this is the most complex part of the
vaccine rollout program so far
um and you know NHS staff have done I
think an incredible job they've stepped
up every time there's been a change and
responded magnificently through the
whole of the past year with the as the
program has expanded and changed so I
have absolutely no doubt that they will
again on winter you're absolutely right
to say there is significant pressure
I've mentioned some of the pressures on
urgent emergency care as well of course
as continuing to try and uh deal with
some of the backlogs that were
inevitably created across the last 18
months of the pandemic but whilst we are
supporting them with that we have said
very consistently we are expecting this
to be a difficult winter but last year
let's not forget what they achieved
stood up to the second massive increase
in covert cases began that life-saving
vital role out of the vaccine program
and of course dealt with all of the
usual winter pressures as well so I
think we can take great comfort from
what the NHS has done over the last year
and a half and certainly what I see
across the NHS is a huge number of
people pulling out absolutely all the
stops to do the right thing for their
patients uh absolutely right so Emily
Morgan of ritv prime minister should
people be taking your advice or the
advice of one of your scientific
advisors who said we should be limiting
unnecessary social contacts can you see
why people are confused and to you
Amanda even if you did 3.5 million
booster Jabs every single week it would
still take until mid-February by my
calculations to get through all those
who are eligible how are you going to do
it by the end of January
well first of all the the guidance
Remains the Same that doesn't mean that
people shouldn't take a sensible
precautions and everybody should
continue for instance to to wash your
hands and and make sure that you you
have good ventilation and and uh and and
wear a mask when you're in a confined
space with people you don't uh normally
meet what we're doing is we're
toughening up the uh the regulations in
the specific ways that I've outlined uh
to deal with with Omicron I think that's
that's the right approach we're taking a
balanced and a proportionate approach
but uh as I said I think on on Saturday
uh we we still the most important thing
is we still uh think that your best
single protection against all variances
to get the booster and I'm still
confident that this Christmas will be
considerably better than last Christmas
and that that remains my view
48 hours later so
um
uh so look thank you it is our clear
intention to ensure that everyone who is
eligible has a chance to book that
booster by the end of January and in
order to achieve that I've set out a
whole range of things we're going to be
doing there's no maximum to the number
of Jabs that we're aspiring to give a
week on week but what we do need to
recognize is you know this is going to
build up over the next few weeks and
inevitably there will be things that
change and adapt as we go along as has
been the case all the way through the
vaccination program but the range of
things that I've set out does mean that
we have confidence as we said that we
will be able to make sure that all of
those people who are eligible will have
that opportunity to book
great thanks Ben kentish OBC thank you
Amanda just a briefly to meet that
Target at the right end of January you
need about 30 million doses could you
just confirm that there's no issue with
supply of the Pfizer and moderna Jabs
when it comes to that a health secret if
I could just ask you briefly about the
restrictions that came in today
governments in many European countries
have advised their citizens to wear not
just face coverings but specific ffp2 or
n95 medical grade masks because they're
much better at protecting both the
wearer and the people around them as the
rules on Master Titan today would that
be your advice to people here too and
prime minister people could be forgiven
this week for asking when this is all
going to end obviously we know it's not
imminent and the Omicron variant raises
a lot of uncertainty but can you give
people some hope that the day when we
won't have to wear masks we won't have
to test or quarantine when restrictions
can be lifted when that day may come
clearly there's uncertainty it's been
reported that government was planning
initially for it to be potentially next
march is that still the case or just on
the Chrome set that back thank you
thank you I think Amanda you're first
well look thanks to the um outstanding
work of the vaccine task force uh I am
reassured that we absolutely do have the
supply we need
yeah on the face covering so we have
there's already guidance on face
coverings including the types of face
coverings that are recommended and we
see no need to change that I just want
to touch if I maybe I'm on Vicki's
question earlier on the those that are
unvaccinated there it's right to point
to that there's some five million people
throughout the UK that are that haven't
even had one jab and they really are
putting themselves in the harm way that
themselves In Harm's Way and and uh
their loved ones and we really urge them
to come forward and it is right also
when you look at Hospital admissions
that it's a disproportionate number of
people that haven't been vaccinated you
sadly for example if you look at all the
pregnant women that are in hospital
because of covid almost all every single
one almost every single one is
unvaccinated so it's really important
that people come forward and that
Evergreen offer of a vaccine whether
it's for your first dose or your second
dose will always be there we're urging
those people to come forward as well
and uh uh Ben the on your question the
The crucial thing the 64 million dollar
question or billion dollar question
whatever is uh does this new variant
beat the vaccines on and does it beat
the the particularly does it beat the
the booster and as I've as I've said
over the last few days uh we think uh
that the chances are that uh it the
boosters will continue to give a you
protection against every variant of
protection of some degree that's why
it's so absolutely vital uh to get the
boosters uh but we need to check that we
don't we can't this is this is what we
what we think but we need uh to check
that and that's why we're we're waiting
to see what the the science tells us
what I can certainly tell you and is
that the measures that we've uh put in
place uh will not last a minute more uh
than we think are uh they are uh
strictly necessary for the for the
protection of Public Health uh
chasing Graves play him out
thanks um Mr Jeb and you said I think
there's now 13 cases do you think it's
likely that we are now seeing Community
uh transmission uh in England and the
rest of the UK uh Mr could you tell us a
little bit more about what the troops
are going to be doing
uh in this rollout and finally you
talked about a proportionate response
but we are seeing people
uh responding to the news they're seeing
by canceling Christmas parties scrapping
Nativity plays would you urge them to
think again and get this in perspective
yeah yeah first of all uh on on cases
the cases the that we identified at the
weekend at the start of the weekend they
were or we were able to confirm quickly
that they were linked to travel to South
Africa they were also part of one sort
of family cluster the recent cases that
we've uh confirmed today uh we have
we're not able to to say whether or not
at this point was we don't know we're
doing that work right now at speed to
determine whether they all have a link
to South Africa or not is there likely
to be Community transmission I think we
have to be realistic there is likely to
be as we're seeing in other European
countries and also as I said uh earlier
that we we would expect your crisis to
rise as we now actively look for cases
because now having identified uh the the
variant in our concerns around it uh
ukhsas actually looking back at anyone
who's traveled to South Africa over the
last 10 days or so and and searching for
these cases and taking action of course
if they find them
Port all the way through this program
whether that's from volunteers or from
the military or partnership with a whole
range of other community groups and
local governments so you know once again
we will be working with the military in
a range of ways everything from kind of
support Logistics through to actually
providing Jabs but I would just use this
if I may as another big plea for people
if they are interested in thinking about
coming forward as a volunteer because
the volunteer Workforce was critical or
like through the whole of the last year
and really will be again and I know that
the incredibly dedicated staff who are
working in the NHS really value the
support that they get from that
volunteer Workforce and from those wider
partners
thank you yes and Jason just on your
your point about Christmas uh parties
and Nativity players we don't want
people to cancel such events we and and
we think that overwhelmingly uh the best
thing for kids is to be in school as
I've said uh many times throughout this
pandemic what we're doing is is trying
to take a balanced and proportionate uh
approach to the particular risk that is
uh seems to be posed by uh Omicron or
certainly is posed by Omicron uh focused
in particular on measures at the at the
borders and we think that's the that's
the right way to go uh uh for the for
the time being until we know more and
until we can get uh more boosters uh as
as we've been saying into people's arms
can we go to Jasmine uh Cameron chileshi
of DFT please
I just had a couple of questions on the
new restrictions with the changes in the
self-isolation rules businesses in
particular have warned the second
pandemic the potential disruption to um
staff and that sort of thing is that
inevitable as cases rise and do you is
there anything you can say to reassure
businesses and just another point the
government has ruled out plan B but can
you confirm whether contingency measures
are being placed say for example for
work at home for work from home measures
ahead of Christmas and can you rule out
local restrictions for example if
there's a surge of cases in one
particular pocket of the country for
example
uh thanks very very much Jasmine so just
on on the the risks of going back to
where we were in in uh July I I the the
so-called pandemic I don't think that is
uh likely to to happen in the sense that
so far at least uh the numbers of of
cases of of Omicron are are small uh but
you know we'll have to we'll have to see
and uh you know we will have to uh uh
we'll have to keep that uh you know keep
that constantly under under review uh on
the on the on the issue of you asked
about about local measures I I certainly
think that uh We've uh we went around
that a lot uh in in the last year and I
think that uh We've we've settled pretty
much on The View that uh having a as far
as you possibly can moving together is
the is the way to to to do it so you had
a you had a middle question it was just
that the government
thanks Jasmine we haven't uh we haven't
ruled out anything I I've got I've got
to tell you I I think another uh
lockdown of the kind that we've had
before is extremely uh unlikely I'll be
I'll be upfront with you about that uh
but uh we keep everything under constant
review in our fight against
um against the the Delta variant we
think that that it's it's basically been
going uh our way or going the way that
we that we planned so you're seeing
although cases remain uh high or
high-ish uh you're seeing a decline in
the numbers of of admissions to hospital
and a decline in the number of of deaths
and that's the crucial thing that we've
been we've been following so at the
moment uh we sent we've seen we see no
cause to move uh to plan B uh but as
I've said to you many many times before
we've got to keep that under review but
the measures where talking about to deal
with with Omicron are as I've said uh
distinct uh last to Joe Mays of
Bloomberg
and it's just a press on the work from
home Point Scotland Wells and Northern
Ireland are all advising to work from
home if people can so what is your
reasoning around the harms of working
from home and why do those harms
outweigh the public health benefits that
could come from significantly reducing
transmission or potentially dangerous
variant and just briefly on migrants how
do you plan to manage the UK's
relationship with France and when did
you last speak to Emmanuel macron about
the crossings
uh thanks Joe so uh on on your on your
point about working from home this is
this is not something uh that we we
think currently is is necessary for the
reasons I gave to to Jasmine uh we've
got a package of measures that uh we
have in place to deal with
um uh the Delta uh uh their Internet's
principally been rolling out the vaccine
and it's been and it's been working and
I I repeat what I said just now about
the numbers of deaths and
hospitalizations coming down we now have
a particular issue uh to to deal with
the uh the seeding of the uh the new the
potential seeding of the new Omicron
variant and there what we want to do is
uh Focus particularly on tough measures
at the borders we're also doing
something uh something uh to stop
transmission by uh by reintroducing face
masks in in some settings so continually
continue to advise them in in other
settings but but tightening the rules on
face masks and the thinking the the
reason for not proceeding as it were
with the full Plan B uh or or proceeding
with Plan B is we we don't we want to
take an approach that is proportionate
and balanced and Suits the the needs of
the of the of the of the present risk
and I you know of course we will uh
change things as as necessary but what
we're looking for is uh the first real
uh reassurance that we need that the
vaccines are efficacious against uh this
variant even if the efficacity the
effectiveness is reduced uh that's still
it's still very important to know uh
that whether they're they're effective
or not and in particular we need to know
uh quite how effective the boosters are
as I've said uh we think there are good
grounds for believing that the boosters
will give you under all circumstances uh
the protection that you need
considerable protection that's why the
most important thing for everybody to do
is is go out and get your booster that's
the number one thing that people need to
be doing thank you all very much and
listen I just want to say I just want to
say something because nobody's nobody's
asked about it uh so far I just want to
say something about storm Arwin uh in
the and its effect on the on the north
of the of the country and I I just want
to say how uh that the government I'm
extremely sympathetic to everybody who
suffered uh the these power outages and
it is ABS I must be appalling I think a
million homes lost their electricity uh
950 000 have seen uh that uh electricity
now restored but for clearly for 50 000
people that is not good enough and I can
I want to reassure everybody that we're
working as hard as we can to get power
back to to those homes uh all I can say
is the gusts we're going at 100 miles an
hour and talking to the uh the people
who operate the grid they say that they
had absolutely there was nothing that
they could uh do about it but we are
doing everything we can uh to restore uh
Power talking to uh Northern power grid
and everybody else uh to to get that
fixed and I appreciate it must be a very
very tough time for those homes uh that
are currently without power and I'm
afraid that is all uh we have time for
thank you all very much thank you
foreign